hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today I am talking
about more of my time getting to play
Red Dead Redemption to this time I took
a bunch of your questions from Twitter
and Instagram and I'm going to do my
best to answer every single question
that you have keep in mind I hope to
play three hours of the game which
doesn't feel like a lot really that it
felt like 30 minutes alrighty I'm gonna
go through to answer these questions in
no particular order starting with can
you swim now yes but you can't dive did
you notice any framerate drops or
graphical issues I noticed absolutely no
framerate drops none at all but there
were a few graphical issues not many the
game is gorgeous but seemed to appear
and disappear out of nowhere but
specifically in the sky that seem to be
used as like set-dressing sometimes we
just show up and sometimes we just fade
away but Rockstar did mention this build
was about three weeks old so it was not
a final version of the game that I
played I'm also just generally not a fan
of the way that hair looked I know that
it's hard for games to get hair right
but horses tails particularly sort of
like fizzled out at the end it looked
like that like the spray paint tool in
Microsoft Paint not that bad nowhere
near that bad I promise but it just sort
of I don't didn't look like individual
hairs it just fades oddly everything
else looks great especially the density
environments are so full of detail and
things and I don't understand how there
aren't loading screens it's magic I
guess this is just what happens when
rockstar games actually makes a next-gen
title because remember GTA 5 is
technically a 360 ps3 era game they were
just ported it's bonkers how do the l2
interactions work so you talk to NPCs by
holding l2 and looking at them it
doesn't put you in a cutscene doesn't
lock you in you can still freely walk
around while talking to them you can
drink coffee you can buy some whiskey at
a bar and you can still walk around and
talk to people in the bar like in real
life
you have options to greet people you can
rub from the rob them immediately rub
from them you can escalate and
deescalate conversations which means be
aggressive or the kinda and even if you
have fully escalated a conversation and
that you've gotten very very aggressive
with someone you won't necessarily know
how that individual person will respond
because it depends on that individual
person one thing I do want to note
though is that if you are
someone and you kill them or whatever
NPCs have relationships if you kill
someone and they have a cousin somewhere
who can feasibly figure out that you
killed them they will come off to you or
some of them will say it's an aggressive
family and someone in town so you do it
and they also live in town they might
come and try to fight you because you
killed that cousin that is a detail that
I find it saying I did also ask Rockstar
if NPCs would ever repeat themselves
they said no so you can also interact
with items with l2 I don't know if
that's everything but it seems to be
most things
what is the map size I don't know I
expect that it's pretty large they
didn't mention there is fast travel you
can fast travel via trains you can also
hijack train so you don't have to go to
a train station by ticking get on a
train but I did ask what the edges were
if they're invisible walls on mountains
Rockstar would not tell me the answer to
that so I imagine it's the biggest rock
star map to date can you give us any
mealy details so Miele feels like well
in first place and it feels very unique
actually almost like maybe like a little
bit like dying light a little it's
similar to GTA but it's more
choreographed and most motley animated
you can also do stealth takedowns
killcams vary depending on how honorable
you are like it might focus more on how
you've killed someone if you are
dishonorable on the topic of fighting
NPCs I mentioned this earlier but the
bounding system is really cool if
someone witnesses you get in a fight
they can report it unless you manage to
intercept them before they go to the
sheriff
NPCs will react differently to you
intercepting them some of them will be
susceptible some of them won't some of
them might not even tell the sheriff
depending on who they are and the town
even if you've paid off your bounty the
town the area nor the people around you
will still remember whatever you have
done and hold it against you or like you
for it maybe how's the gunplay
to me it feels like GTA combined with
Max Payne just with way more detail
there's a missus but it's not too naggy
the revolver has a really unique firing
mode which is it's like once to [ __ ] it
and then wants to shoot which you can
use to intimidate people so you could
like pull it back hold it at the head
just to like you know tell them that you
mean business and that is individually
animated there is
from the hip mode where if you just like
tap are too rapidly you'll shoot from
the hip which is great for like things
like ambushes you can shoot into the sky
to just intimidate people to get
attention or to like a lot an animal or
something like that you can involve
people's heads and limbs and all that
good stuff if you tap l1 as well Otto
will put his gun away with a flourish so
I like spin it and then put it in his
holster it's it's really cute and and
every time that he interacts with the
stuff that's on his body he actually
interacts with it so like it doesn't
clip through it just it actually like
fits in you know he actually puts it
it's he actually does it it's just Oh
Arthur's dead I also develops I think we
probably had it on level 102 but as it
develops Rockstar said he'll be able to
target critical areas like an enemies
vital organs which is going to be super
useful for getting clean kills while
hunting and we will get into hunting but
give me a bit someone else is cleaning
your guns annoying I don't think so
there is weapon degradation and that is
that your gums get dirty if they get wet
you have to clean them so you'll have to
be aware if you're in water but cleaning
them is pretty simple you can do it at
any point in time I imagine you'll be
able to do it while talking to people so
say is sitting around the campfire and
you're talking to the NPC's or your gang
members you'll be able to clean your gun
you can sit on pretty much anything as
well and the weapons basically they
don't break they just the performance
lessens and it didn't seem like it was
happening very quickly because we didn't
have to clean it at all in my
playthrough I just chose to at one point
but basically it'll just keep them at
peak performance if they get dirty it'll
like they'll start jamming maybe reload
times would be slower and things like
that I think what is the weapon wheel
like it's really someone to GTA 5 but a
little more realistic about what you can
carry you can have two one-handed guns
and two two-handed weapons which doesn't
include knives like throwing knives or
like molotovs you can leave additional
items in your saddlebags which is very
new you could leave like a bow and arrow
on the side of your horse so if you're
hunting and you want it you know you got
your guns on offer you get off the horse
you grab your bow and arrow off of the
horse and then you put it back so it's
just a lot more realistic about what you
can carry on you in any given time will
animals attack
horse I didn't see that but I suspect
that they will so there was a point
where I was standing
relatively still Oh doing we were doing
dressage I think and the horse freaked
out because Rockstar thinks that it's
because the horse saw a rattlesnake so
it was panicking about something so
you're still in control majority of the
time but yes I would imagine that
animals will attack your horse they're
more likely to attack it's like hungry
but you don't necessarily know if
they're hungry or not also for some
reason you can wear animal carcasses as
a hat because why not I guess I wanted
to talk about some more horse stuff if
you lose your horse it'll go back to
your camp but as long as it's not too
far away you can whistle to call it if
you lose your horse you can ask a
passerby for a ride if you're stuck
without it you can also use someone
else's horse and I believe that you can
have two active horses at once but I
don't think you can just have a full
arsenal of horses but you can visit a
stable to customize your horse you can
switch out stirrups blankets saddles
reins saddle horns all that stuff you
can also change the style of its mane
and tail so you can cut those I'm not
sure if they grow like Arthas does but I
would say yes but you can also like
breed and end dreadlock them and all
that stuff and yes if your horse dies
it's gone you can't just get it back
like you can in gta5 with an insurance
claim it is gone so if you've put all
that time into bonding with your horse
and levelling up that bond so it's not
as skittish if it sees something or it's
not as skittish in in gunfights or you
know bond will make it follow you
but on that note you can tell your horse
to flee if you're in a scary situation
in order to save its life so you can
make your horse run away so that it
won't die which i think is very cool how
overwhelming did it feel fairly but not
in a off-putting way there's a lot to do
but that a lot is more about the
exploration like Rockstar kept asking us
if we they were like they kept being
like what do you what do you want to do
now when we're just like hanging out in
a stall looking at things and I think
it's the fact that I can see myself
getting distracted constantly because
everything is so interesting which is
maybe daunting you know in a way that
it's like I don't know how quickly I'm
going to want to play through this game
because there's so much to see like
maybe I could put hundreds of
into this game because I'm just
interested because I could talk to every
NPC and every time it will be not
necessarily every time it will be
different but depending on the context
it'll be different so I don't feel like
it's overwhelming in a way that's that's
padding like most modern video games
where they just add a bunch of arbitrary
[ __ ] for you do in Red Dead
Redemption - it could be overwhelming
because everything you have to do is
interesting and because you are going to
consistently be interested by everything
around you and that is what sets it
apart from virtually every other
open-world game I've seen people saying
this is like next level up in wargaming
and I fully agree it's not fetch quests
or hidden things or you know the same
repeated instance just in different
areas it really is that the whole world
just happens to be interesting and not
in a way that's video gaming not in a
way that it feeds into your quest
objective necessarily it's just
interesting I hope that it takes me a
long time to finish because I I really
do want to just get stuck in this world
that's the thing I'm most excited about
is the HUD is the thing where when you
turn the HUD off the NPC's give you more
directions real no it seems like maybe
people who are playing with the HUD off
just felt like they noticed it more than
NPCs give you directions when they're
hard was off but no they will always say
the same stuff to you no matter what
what don't you like about it very little
there might be too much horseback
segments maybe like I feel like you're
gonna be doing a lot of riding in this
game and you don't necessarily have that
much to do while you're riding you're
just travelling between the map I'm not
sure yet uh and I thought that some of
the stars look too big like I guess if
they get to be galaxies some of them
just look like big big old white blobs
in the sky that's it
everything else was great how much of a
role does music play a pretty
significant role it builds depending on
the circumstance so it might be like
kind of light if you're just about to
start into combat but you're still in
stealth mode or something and music that
plays will vary depending on your
alignment which i think is very cool the
skull was beautiful as well it was the
sound design in general was
this is gonna win so many different
categories of Game of the Year awards
you guys it's bunk is is their crafting
and what is it like yes you can craft mo
and tools and healing items and all that
good stuff you collect herbs around the
world you I just said herbs hubs around
the world
I mean you crafted a campfire including
it just random campfires and you might
find around the world and I think you
can craft in other places as well
imagine you can just croft it generally
in the wild but maybe you get more
options it can't buy it's not fully sure
but yes there is crafting and also just
a ton of customization of everything
ever everything is customizable you can
engrave your guns custom and I imagine
you can put quite a lot of work into
them and I think the idea behind that is
to give you a sense of attachment to
everything that you have like you can
name your horse you have a bond with
your horse so you feel attached to your
horse so that horse dies you're gonna
feel sad I think the same applies to
your weapons you can engrave them you
make them yours you could name them you
can you know think of them fondly and I
think the idea that is maybe because
your inventory is smaller obviously
that's on a mechanic that's that's a
style choice to make the game realistic
but again maybe that's there so that you
will feel more attached to everything in
the game and I think that goes with
their mission statement of everything
should feel important like every NPC you
talk to will be interesting to talk to
you same applies your to your items
what's hunting like I didn't do a ton of
hunting but it sounds fairly standard to
me you can take a thing that prevents
your scent as a hunter because animals
can track you depending on whether wind
is so if you're upwind from them they
will be able to smell you it's
recommended that you hunt with say a bow
and arrow
rather than with the shotgun because the
way that you hunt will alter the quality
of the pelts that you get so if you get
a headshot for example on a deer with a
bow and arrow that's going to do a lot
less damage to a pelts than a shotgun
would so the pelt will be more valuable
you can make more stuff out of it or
better quality stuff out of it you can
also leave an animal caucus somewhere to
draw other animals in like if you leave
a dead animal it will start to decompose
and then other animals will be able to
smell that and come to you what's
cooking like Arthur can cook cooking
will give you stat boosts you'll gain
weight if you eat too much you'll lose
weight and become going to if you don't
eat enough they're all just like a bunch
of
elements but they're all light it's not
a hardcore survival game something me to
punishing you're looking at tide if you
don't sleep you'll have less stamina if
you're carrying something you will be
affected by climates in terms of stamina
as well but not die like you're doing
breath of the wild and all of that stuff
is tracked by things called cores which
just come up above your minimap they're
just so if that's your mini-map they're
like little dots above it and they have
different there's an outline on the
outside that tells you how full that
thing is and then on the inside it tells
you its level of regeneration um other
things that I wanted to note gang
members will loot
if you don't loot so they can steal your
loot so you kind of need to be aware of
that and that is it for me today
everyone thank you all so much for your
questions let me know if you have any
more below like I said earlier I should
be getting more time with the game soon
so I'll be able to answer even better
some of that will be embargoed but I'll
get it to you as soon as I can
alrighty that is it for all of the Red
Dead Redemption I love you all so much
and I'll see you next time